hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cryo em in discovery and rational
engineering of biologics i am jennifer
woods of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
yuri iozo
senior scientist at sanofi and dr dan
cannon
senior scientist too at schrodinger dr
iozo and dr cannon you may now begin
your presentation
hello everyone my name is yuriya yozo
i'm a senior scientist at sanofi
large molecular research division in
united states
today i will talk about our integrated
structural biology approach
which is focused on the small protein
complexes
as you know in last 80 years cryo made a
tremendous progress
and it became a staple tool in
structural biology research
initially it was successful very
successful with high molecular weight
complexes but over the years
it progressed and
was able to uh provide structures for
smaller and smaller and smaller targets
few years ago hundred kilodaltons
appeared appeared to be a barrier for
cryorium
and to this day it remains like this
because uh for such small particles
signal-to-noise ratio is quite low on
the micrographs
another common issue in cryo-em is
so-called the problem of preferred
orientation
and water air interface these two
problems are interconnected they're
slightly different but very connected to
each other
and this uh dramatic problem which any
crayon scientist probably encountered
always leads to a difficulty of
reconstructing high quality maps
maps tricking excessive noise and in
very severe situations total inability
to reconstruct a meaningful map
it also increases computational cost and
time
involved in the project in the project
progress
so based on those two big problems
there was always a question uh can you
make a
criem as successful in industrial
research
as uh x-ray for a few years after crying
revolution
industrial research was lagging behind
academia it was
standing on sidelines and watching how
the major hurdles
in crime will be overcome in academia
eventually crayon
labs started to pop up across uh
across different pharmaceutical
companies
so in this presentation i want to show
how we answer the question
whether the criem could be more
successful than x-ray
in industrial setting
so today
i will talk about our pipeline our
framework for our
structural biology research which is
focused on crying
and focused on the small size comp
complexes i will go through the details
of this pipeline on the next slide
but on this slide i want to say what
advantages do we get
by using this framework this pipeline
first of all first of all because we
have this decision tree
we may be able to make very quick
decisions
without thinking what potential problems
can come down the road
also each step has a limited amount of
options so we can make
easy decisions because a choice when
choices
uh to when you have too many choices
becomes
very difficult so by limiting these
options decisions are very quick
which in turn leads to the faster
deliveries we were able to ensure
timely delivery in near hundred percent
of the
cases in our company and of course
by using this framework and have limited
options it's very good to predict the
use of resources
uh cost and which is good for the
budgeting
and planning and i think the one thing i
want to point out
uh which is i think the main
characteristic of
of our pipeline is that we have a clear
priority
our priority is always a delivery so
we always try to get the information to
the project team to push the candidate
further up down the drug development
pipeline
we don't do resolution chasing once we
have enough resolution to address
project needs
we redirect our resources to other
projects
of course when there is a clear
scientific purpose
for example for method development or
publication potential
we can spend additional time just for
scientific
scientific benefit on the project and
try to improve the data
but generally we focus on delivery not
on the resolution chases
and it kind of relieves us from the
guilt and constraints uh
of for some ukrainian scientists
experience
of course there are some uh downsides
for example in order to speed up
our timelines the hundred percent
relevant cross
we don't operate microscopes ourselves
and
of course there is no guarantee of
success in often in the
um time constraint of industrial
research you always have to settle
uh not always you sometimes have to
settle for
less than four angstrom resolution if
their third optimization is lengthy
so i want to talk a little bit about the
details of this pipeline so
after we check that our complex form
through the size occlusion
chromatography then we analyze the
complex
we check its molecular weight symmetry
presence of glycans or flexible tags
and then based on these parameters we
choose appropriate method
for most of the targets lower than 50
kilodaltons
we use x-ray unless it's impossible
because target proven before difficult
or impossible to crystallize or it has
glycans
which important for the structure or for
example
it would be very difficult to dig like
like diglycosylate the
uh complex so uh in all other cases with
we start with crying when we do grid
screening and data collection
we will try to use limited options you
know that for example buffer is very
important for crayon sample it's one of
the most important thing to find the
proper buffer for the sample to make
sure your
complex feels good on the grids but
using these optimizations for every
single project or complex would be
such a tremendous loss of time
tremendous loss of time and it's not
feasible in our setting
so through our experience with limited
our options to
two to four buffers which we
use on every single complex and nearly
hundred percent of the time
this choice of one of those four buffers
was enough
and um for example we use only gold
grids in our uh
data screening and data collection of
course gold grades come with the premium
but they've proven themselves to be the
most most robust and most consistent
with delivering a better results
of course sometimes we have to mitigate
preferred orientation orientation for
high molecular weight complexes
over 100 kilodaltons we use classical
attempt
options like stage tilt or use of
detergent
but for the lower molecular weight
complexes we discovered that
using another strategy of 18 additional
binder
is way more helpful usually when there
is a candidate in development the
pipeline would have
probably a few more candidates with
different epitope bins
so if you see a strong preferred
orientation why not to try to add
another candidate
in hope that the complex behavior will
change on the grids and you will
you will be able to overcome preferred
orientation
even if you don't have another candidate
there's often commercial fabs available
which you can add to your complex not
only it can change the complex behavior
but it can
increase molecular weight which will
push you out of the envelope
of below 100 kelvins and of course
when we have our data we uh when we use
a microscope we use micro microscopes
very efficiently
usually within 20 we have 20 or we order
24 hour shifts on the crease microscopes
and we use it initially for grid
screening and then for overnight data
collection
on average we used one crate
rios shift per one delivery
when we get the data we always try to
process it very fast
so we figure
we learned that the system is
the best way to access as the initial
quality of the data it's super fast
it doesn't require doesn't quite
require any heavy computational heavy
expensive computational resources
and it can give you results within hours
and if the results are good enough for
delivery we stop we switch to another
project
however if the results are not good
enough we can switch to more complicated
uh data processing pathways like using
reliance which is
more costly in lengthy of course if
some companies have advantage of
cryospark that's also very fast
software but considering the license
is very expensive it's not as cost
effective as system
when we get to our data we do rigid uh
final maps we do rigid body feeds if the
resolution is high enough very fine
our structures if not relax rigid by
defeats
via molecular dynamics in the low
resolution maps
and then immediately with the uh do
delivery we
not only deliver this structure to the
project
team we do all kind of jobs for them
like structure analysis different
structure based predictions uh affinity
maturation and risk mitigation proposals
on the next few slides i will just show
four examples of uh
of the different cases uh from our
pipeline
it's there will be no like order from
most easy to most difficult they're
totally different
with total uh with totally different
type of deliveries and
problems so the first case
is trimeric antigen bound to the uh
to the fab as initially physiologically
this
antigen even its molecular weight be 400
kilodaltons because it's trimeric
it's uh pushes its molecular weight to
the tremor above
about 100 kilodaltons so always take
advantage of the symmetry
and three fabs are bound to the antigen
bring it above
200 200 kilo dalton so it's not even
close to the size the area and the
strategy of using four buffers works
very fine
it works actually for nearly all
our projects so it was very easy to
choose appropriate buffer out of four
and to get diverse 2d orientations once
we got the data
just within hours of processing a system
in system we got 4.1 angstrom
map in this 7 symmetry a couple hours
later it was already 3.5 inch from f7
the c3 symmetry so this resolution was
totally enough to
provide the all needed deliveries to the
team
including epitope mapping and deliver
developability risk mitigation
so the total time of the project was one
week and data processing literally just
few hours second case
is a very interesting where i will
explain the strategy of using additional
binders
so uh this is a complex a very small
antigen
with a nanobody originally
we tried to solve the structure for
of this antigen with nanobody b1 and
the data showed strong preferred
orientation
and with the dominant view similar to
shown on panel a
we were only able to obtain five inks
from there but it was not nearly enough
for the project needs because
team required a mode of action and we
needed higher resolution for the
multi-specific design
then we thought why not to
look for the second uh binder hopefully
it would alter
the complex behavior and give us
additional fuse
views and indeed we found the second
candidate in the pipeline
and used it to on nana body b2
so the complex with uh two nanobody
still showed preferred orientation but
it showed significant amount of the
rare views as as shown on the
panel b d so
from the new data we were able to
reconstruct 3.4
instrument map for the complex which
molecular weight
was below 90 kilodaltons including
glycans and
it had seven symmetry i think at this
point we
accidentally hit the world record among
at least published data
for the highest resolution for the
smaller molecule smallest molecular
weight complex with no symmetry
uh this resolution was great to do to
provide
all the deliveries to the project team
and uh
with high confidence and it just showed
the power of
uh using additional binders instead of
instead of spending tons of time on
collecting
new data and do the buffer detergent
buffer
and tilt optimizations
um this case study also shows that
not necessary you have to have a high
resolution to provide the deliveries
so this antigen complex with the fab
has molecular weight about 100
kilodaltons right on the brink of the
sized area
the crystallography was not acceptable
here because the glycans were needed in
the structure couldn't be removed
so uh we tried cryovm and the complex
showed preferred orientation
stage still didn't improve the results
so instead of going
results we needed results uh relatively
quickly so instead of
doing lengthy optimizations with
uh detergents and buffers we
opted into collecting larger data sets
hoping to uh to enrich our data with
rare views
and after removing some uh
some dominant use we obtained rare views
and were able to reconstruct focusing
map
uh surprisingly the quality of map was
very good not only
even at this resolution only only we
were able to determine the mode of
action and its application
but we were able even to do the affinity
alteration proposal for the fab
which worked so uh it shows the power
that
uh of the criem that resolution is
shouldn't be the constraint
it should be a nice feature to have but
you don't necessarily have to hunt for
the high resolution to do the successful
deliveries
and the last case study is very tiny
antigen
uh only 20 kilodaltons in complex with
the fab
so crystal x-ray failed on non-glute
isolated antigen so the x-ray was
only option in this situation so
um as for many small complexes you see
that very strong preferred orientation
so initially
after we collected uh first data we
couldn't even
obtain the ab initio map that uh how bad
was the preferred orientation
so because we had to do the delivery in
this situation we had to
uh there was no way to use additional
binder
so we had to use detergents and state
tilts
and eventually we were able to obtain
these rare views with uh
very noisy rear views but they allowed
to
finally us to reconstruct to obtain the
reconstruction obtained the map
very very low resolution map but it
helped to guide
and uh docking of the fab
to the antigen and it helped us to
coarsely assign the epitope it's
actually what that
all what the team needed in this
situation is of course they assigned the
epitope
so this still was a successful delivery
uh
on this slide i just want to show the
summary what
we've done using our structural biology
framework
pipeline in the last 24 months so
basically from beginning 2019 to be
from the middle of 2019 to till now
so in this 24 month with approximately
only two full-time employees very very
very small structural biology group
we were able to deliver 38
the different structures 25
of which were crying so we near we
delivered
approximately one crying structure every
month and
approximately one x-ray structure every
two months
but as you can see that the crayon is
the majority because it can solve the
options
uh give you solutions for problems
x-ray cannot especially when you talk
about glycosylated
uh glycosylated antigens and
uh getting the
getting your results fast because if you
go
and try to crystallize and it takes long
time
of course in some situations
crystallization is quick
not always but if you have like glycan
the crying is the only option
so i think this success of delivering
cities uh structures
it shows that uh the power of qurayam in
the industrial setting
in the last slide i want to
[Music]
acknowledge our my sanofi colleagues
first of all you chew
who is my fellow structural biologist
from our group
and albert who was some in turn helping
us with computational
uh uh projects and of course the
management hyunsen
anna maria and some of the project teams
material generation groups nit
department and of course big things to
go
uh to umass medical school harvard
medical school
university of michigan which are our
cryencia
roads and i think this presentation
helped you to
prove that the crying could be more
successful than x-ray
in the pharmaceutical setting thank you
i think i now turn over to the end
yes thank you thank you yuri so
um i now should have control of the
screen
and yeah so first of all i'd like to
thank the
organizers for inviting me to speak
um the title of my talk um here can be a
little bit
long-winded but i prefer that
maybe we think about it in the context
of computational design
of biologics so um
first of all um why would we
um sort of use computation at all well
the first thing to note is that
computation
is uh it has a requirement of structures
and yuri's already talked about the
different ways of utilizing triuem
to obtain such structures
and so where do we take it in the next
stage um so
um utilizing those structures to enable
design um
is is one of the biggest things um i
think
one of the expect ways forward um
this is because traditionally when we um
you know design therapeutic molecules
and we take an experimental approach
um we take kind of brute force
approaches and what i mean by that is
that we
do saturation mutagenesis or you know
block mutagenesis and then through that
process you know
you have to design um make you know and
test the variance and this can take a
lot of
you know resources both in terms of time
and
of money um and
often like in these cases it's not
structure enabled therefore you don't
have any kind of
rationale um to sort of understand where
the variants are or
you know which ones are good which ones
are bad you're just kind of
you know running a brute force approach
and filtering out
those which are not desirable and so
this is where
um in silico design approach can maybe
negate
many of these challenges um
so relatively speaking actually running
um
mutations and testing uh the relative
affinity or stability
is is actually fairly cheap um compared
to doing this experimentally
again both both in terms of cost and in
terms of time
um and what you um can also gain from
that and using these structures
is that you can have you know analysis
much more in-depth analysis and
understanding of
why certain mutations behave the way
they do
and because um we can do that we can
also
easily optimize multiple properties at
the same
time so as yuri was leading to
some developability issues etc these can
be
addressed earlier on in the process
so when we utilize computational
approaches
we as i kind of alluded to that we want
to understand
the change in binding affinity upon
mutation
or in either binding affinity or
physical stability
and the way that we do this is really by
trying to solve this thermodynamic cycle
that we see here
on the left in the case of binding
affinity where red would be the wild
type
and green would be the variant
compared and the way we do that is
measure and complex and measure
in the unbound state with physical
stability it's slightly different and
that we
measure the the actual folding protein
compared to
the unfolded protein but in principle
this is what we're trying to do
and so at schrodinger um we utilize um
a technology called free energy
perturbation or fep
um we enhanced
sampling molecular dynamics techniques
and the way that this works in principle
is that we sort of slowly morph um
one of our um you know our wild type
side chain into our variant side chain
so in this case
example on the right hand side this is
an isoleucine to methionine
and as we um as we make this
change we can actually derive
sort of true free energies
and because we utilize um uh
enhanced sampling techniques um we have
a lot more confidence
um in the in the actual method itself
and so what i'd like to do is just to
um give you a little bit of a couple of
case studies
where such techniques can be applied
so in this example
of anti-hiv antibodies
traditionally hiv is quite a difficult
um
disease to treat and or vaccine against
because
there's such low sequence similarity
between different subtypes and uh
of course that means it's difficult to
to define your your target
um however it's been observed that in a
few um
uh hiv infected individuals um they
actually
develop in some cases broadly
neutralizing antibodies
after a few years and what this means is
that these are antibodies which
um bind to several different subtypes
um and so an example like this
understanding the binding
characteristics of these antibodies
you know can actually help to help you
in the
design of uh prophylactic drugs um
and so this is uh where we took a case
study in this case
so um these um anti-hiv antibodies
um are typically binding to uh gp120
which is a surface glycoprotein on this
um
quote unquote extracellular spike um and
so
in this case uh there were three
antibodies of interest that's vrc01
vrc03
and vrc pg04
and so the aim of of the study was to
really kind of
characterize the the binding interfaces
using alanine scanning something that
you would do
experimentally but um can take you know
quite a while um and again it doing it
in silico
you negate the um the typical challenges
of
um expressing and uh and testing and so
on
and so you can accelerate the process
using uh computational techniques
and of course in this
using uh using alanine scanning we hope
to identify sites which are of course
necessary for binding and look for
engineering
opportunities one thing to note is that
because gpu 120 is a glyco
protein that there are indeed some
structural uh implication
of glycans and again this can matter of
course in a cryo-em
and an x-ray type context
but it also makes a difference when we
consider
computation as well
so we run these calculations
for relative binding affinity across all
three
antibody antigen complexes and what we
found was that our errors across all
systems combined
was less than one kilocal per mole
and what this really means is that we're
really approaching
uh experimental levels of of accuracy
as and so this is really now can be
thought of
uh as an incelico assay um
what we found was that explicit explicit
inclusion of mutations with gly
um glycan contacts um
it remains challenging because of course
what we um
unless we have detailed information on
the glycans it can be ambiguous
in certain cases we have to make uh
approximations
however um you know with some of the
refinement methods that
yuri's mentioned including molecular
dynamics we can have a bit more
certainty on
their actual positioning and their role
and so
just maybe overall to to kind of give
you a sense of
um yeah how well does this correlate
with the experiment
well in terms of pure error um in the
combined systems we see
an error of 0.64 when we don't include
glycan cases
and a piercing correlation of around
0.62
and so this is the the graph of that
data on the right hand side
and what you can see is that if you were
to use this technology
in a prospective manner you can
you can almost very clearly
pick out mutations which will improve
your affinity
those which will be detrimental to your
affinity and
as i've already did already this can be
done in a much
quicker manner as well but again
for this currently we need uh structures
and this is where
cryom and x-ray come in
another thing that's um yeah so maybe
just to
summarize on this um we didn't have
access to crystal structures
in all cases we actually had to use sort
of um
superposition and you know as an
analogy to protein docking um and in
cases like that we
introduce ambiguity and so this is again
stressing the importance of
of having uh having docking sorry having
uh crystal structures
or cryorium structures to enable this
type of work
um again in just a again a small
technical inclusion that inclusion and
of glycans
improves accuracy where you have direct
contacts because
in cases like that is much
to really include those explicitly
another sort of uh case study is
actually looking at protein
thermal stability this is extremely
important um
when you're thinking about the uh the
behavior of your your proteins as you
keep them you know
as you store them um i mean something
some proteins of course need to be
stored at
very low temperatures to for them to be
active in three
six months etc and so improving thermal
stability can also
um you know be very useful in this sense
um
in this case study um we uh we looked at
a few
proteins um and some data from a public
data set where we were able to
measure the uh the relative thermal
stability
and just one what i'd like to point out
here is that in this study
um there's uh mutations of a different
type so we cover um you know
you know analogous a polar to a polar as
well as uh
you know polar to acidic type mutations
and so
again we have quite broad coverage um
in this in this scenario
and so what we find is that the
technology is really
um is quite agnostic um to the
um agnostic to the system
uh in question so this can be really
applied to any
uh type of system um so here from barnes
to
license same systems and so on um and
again what we see is excellent accuracy
across multiple systems
um we did serve a few um
outliers um so the technology is not
purely flawless yet
um so in cases where we see um pka
changes
um we do need to sort of account for
this by making certain corrections
um in cases where this disulfide bridges
that's much more
difficult to to predict just purely on a
even on a topology basis
and again um when we do hydrophobic uh
core sort of reorganization when we make
mutations uh very much at the core of
the protein
that's that's can be a little bit uh
more difficult
however in cases uh in most cases
what we see is that we have errors again
on the order of
uh less than one kilo kilo per mole a
few that are slightly more
and but again these type of calculations
can provide you
a lot to value much more quickly than
you uh
can do experimentally and so i think
there's a lot of value in using
cryo-em structures and x-ray structures
followed by um using free energy
perturbation techniques
to actually design your protein and
engineer properties that are desirable
um and yeah so application of physics
based methods can be applied to um you
know
many um systems for affinity and
uh stability um and
again to be iterate they're approaching
experimental uh
levels of accuracy and you don't need to
take uh brute force
improve force uh approaches and so on
um but of course as again as i think um
we're all aware structural informations
are really unnecessary
prerequisites and the technology models
can be useful
but a certain degree can introduce
uncertainty
and so greater structural detail is
always
is always desired and so yeah just to
finish off just to acknowledge
um the people that worked on these two
uh different studies that i've
discussed here and uh again just to
point you in the direction of those
papers if indeed you would like to to
know a little bit more and with that
then i'd like to thank you for your
attention and hand back to jen
for questions
all right thank you dr iozzo and dr
cannon for your informative
presentations
joining us now for the q and a portion
of the webinar
we have nasdaq rajaina and kasim
sader from thermo fisher scientific if
you have a question you would like to
ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first
question
oh we have lots of questions coming in
my screen's jumping okay
so here our first question what do you
mean by greater than two orientations
all right uh uh thank you i think it's
important question
so when you do the 2d classification of
your data
when you have a strong preferred
orientation you see the one dominant
uh typically one of or
two dominant orientations if you have
two or more dominant orientations you
can deal with that but if you have one
likely your map reconstruction would
fail because you just
don't have any any other views so if we
see the
two dominant orientations we try to
solve the problem computationally
they have two or more if we have
for example one and in the
dominant orientation we understand that
it has to be solved
through the sample optimization of the
date or the data collection optimization
all right thank you dr iozo next
question here is also for yuri
was all your data collected with
ultrafloral grids
yes i see this question thank you for
the question i think i see another
question about using graphene grids
so i think i can combine and answer them
both
yes right now for the last small
year and a half we use exclusively uh
gold grids previously we use all kinds
of grids
carbon carbon coated graphene coated
but why we decided to stick to the gold
grids because they're most consistent
yes of course there are some grids could
be advantages in the
some situations but with graphene grids
sometimes you see the problems that
samplers get destroyed on this crate or
you see that the
graphene film is not uniform or if you
have issue of the loss
low contrast so we cannot really take
the
that many risks in hope to get the best
data
but when we don't see that consistency
the gold grids have proven to be the
most consistent and why
why we choose them and use them now
exclusively
okay thank you again uh dr iozo thanks
for answering both of those questions
this next question is directed at dan so
for dan
how do you take into account protein
flexibility in your fep calculations
and is it important to consider
flexibility or the crystal cryo em
structure
is that enough for a good comparison
with your data
yeah so good question so in terms of um
accounting for flexibility then the
the method that we use this fep method
is coupled with enhanced sampling
um molecular dynamics and so
the system is constantly moving and
adjusting
and indeed the local environment is uh
is
doing that um and
to answer the second part of the
question um
yeah the crystal cryem structure isn't
enough for a good comparison with
experimental data
yeah um that we've found i mean
um again you don't necessarily always
have to chase the resolution higher
resolution means that you have
um you know lower ambiguity however
you can um refine certain structures
with
molecular dynamics and create an
ensemble of different
um of states of your your protein
so yeah indeed crystal structures crying
structures um
yeah very sufficient as an input for
for such technology
all right great thank you dr cannon and
i have another question for you
are there protein to protein docking
tools you have used
uh yes indeed so um actually within
schrodinger's suite we use
a tool called piper which is our protein
protein docking tool but it's actually
the proprietary version of the cloth pro
server
um which um in the
capri competitions um is
ryan calls near the top or typically
first
um and so we we license that and
actually add in
sort of certain other features so yeah
um protein protein docking and again it
can be a useful tool
um it's best if you can enrich that with
some
you know intuition about your system or
some knowledge about your system
uh this is true for all docking tools um
but yeah
um i've used a number of different tools
in my uh
in my career so far
all right thank you dr cannon another
question here
for dr iozo what are the four typical
buffers you mentioned in the case
studies
yes of course it's not a secret this
presentation actually translates into
the work we have recently pre-published
on
by archive and uh right now it's on the
peer review uh
in a journal uh it's not a secret that's
uh we use actually it's quite simple uh
we
basically use four different ph's seven
seven and a half
each in half and for ph seven we use
hippies buffer with supplemented with
sodium chloride
uh imidazole buffer for seven and a half
and two heated
uh two threes buffers for eight eight
and a half they're quite simple
uh we tested so many buffers over the
years and they've
proven to be the just the sweet spot and
i think there is a
another uh question related to them
you what kind of concentrations for
proteins we used in this table where we
summarized
our achievements over the last two years
yeah the sweet spot for the protein
concentration for crime is
always about 0.2 max per ml and
some projects lower some projects higher
i don't remember exactly 0.2 seems to be
a switch
spot for start to start optimization for
x-ray of course it's much higher
are we frozen
we can put another note there yeah maybe
you can jump in kasim
yeah absolutely um so the question about
auto focusing during data collection
using gold grids
what do you do for that so as i said
we don't we don't do the data collection
ourselves we're familiar i'm actually
come
with the from the background using
hands-on experience
of course we use an additional grid
for that but we leave it in the
hands of our cross it's our choice to
facilitate our deliveries
so we abstract ourselves from the data
collection but of course there are
technical uh solutions around that and
it works very fine it usually you you
you put an
uh some standard
in addition to your grids into the
cassette
um i can mention that also that for that
autofocusing does work
fine on gold grids with or without
objective aperture
so there's actually no problem with
doing that just on the gold itself
thank you for calling
it all right thank you both i had some
technical difficulties so you'll see
there's an extra me or a blank space but
we'll just keep going here our next
question
okay let's find my place
another tip for dr
um if i hear you correctly
the question was was there any project
where we have to change the resolution
right
so yes it was actually key study number
two
when initially we had only five extra
map but we had
high detail we needed high resolution
details to
uh elaborate on modification and for
this
specifically for the designs um
so where this
second binder strategy came very handy
and it's proven over and over and over
again i think it's very successful
strategy of adding additional binders we
had to bring resolution below five
and we were able to do it to bring it uh
to 3.4 of course it was extensive
computation using reliant
lengthy expensive but i think
we brought it to 3.4 and i think it's a
broke that broke the record
at least among the published data at the
time
all right thank you again dr iozo and
this question next question is for dr
cannon what is the typical protein size
for
fep plus calculations
yeah well um good question i think
that's actually there's another question
that
relates to this as well that's i can
answer both at the same time
so um there's not really a limit
on the size of protein that you can use
um
i think that um if you include the
entire protein construct
um will you get more value from it um
then perhaps perhaps not
so if you're making a mutation um at one
um side of a large molecule one site
on a large molecule then you may want to
just approximate around that site so for
example if you are running on an
antibody
um you may not want to include the full
igg
you may want to include the fe or even
the fab and what we've
seen is that as long as the fe is stable
you know in the context of with and
without the fab then
it it doesn't introduce any large
fluctuations within the
calculation therefore you can keep the
system smaller
that being said if you do feel that it's
necessary to include
uh larger systems then um
then you you can and the way that this
scales is typically
as it would for typical molecular
dynamics um
jobs so um it is
the most expensive part is the
non-bonded interactions
um and so this is mostly water so if
you're
including a lot of solvent in your
system then it becomes more expensive
but yeah if you can keep the system
smaller and get that useful information
and indeed
in most cases especially with binding
affinity
you you can keep systems truncated
so i hope that's that's clear if not
then please
do ask a follow-up question
all right thanks again dan we have
another question here for yuri
could you please comment on your
computational resources i.e local versus
cloud computing
yeah i think it's a great question
because different labs have different
uh access to these resources
so i would say that uh more than
half of the projects i mentioned in the
table
no majority i would say i mentioned in
the table were done on the local
computational resources
so of course we have workstations with
we don't have um
workstations with uh so
hundreds of the processors uh
we have local workstations with dozens
of the processes
it's usually good enough for uh to run
very quick jobs and system
or run on medium or
uh medium and length jobs in reliance
the reliance would take few days
system usually few hours of course we
have
we have a cluster where we can run the
system but there is no too much
advantage of running system on cluster
versus
on locally uh right now of course we
have access to the cloud computing we
started to utilize it very actively
including cryospark and reliant
using the cloud but i would say it's not
critical for deliveries if you
concentrate on the delivery not change
the resolution
you will be able to optimize your
workflow here with the if you have a
limited amount of resources
which we proved over the years because
we got this
luxury only recently
there is actually another related
question i think you may have answered
this indirectly
somebody was asking here has computation
time of the structure
i.e rely on cryospark ever been the
bottleneck
yeah it's actually in every project
pretty much on majority of projects it's
a bottleneck unless you use can use
system for your deliveries if the
resolution is good enough in system
it's always a bottleneck reliant
the bottleneck is computational cost and
time
for cryospark it's license cost and also
uh in the resource cost
and uh i think the
people who develop in software have a
ballpark to developing something which
works as fast as a system but
can produce a little better results
comparing to reliant you know
spark right thank you dr iozo
we've got another question here can we
solve structure
of 30 kilodalton protein dimer by
cryo-em
i would say if anything is possible
um because um
we've shown we could go on the 80 90
kilo dungeons
including glycans so actual molecular
weight is much lower
up to inks 3.4 so if you have a dimer 60
kilo dalton
potentially you can but it's all depends
whether
you always have preferred orientation or
not
so if you have some binders which you
can throw on
throw on commercial binders binders from
your pipeline
just increase the molecular weight to
increase your chance of success
but potentially if you don't have any
binders it's still
there is a potential day it doesn't uh
does it doesn't hurt to try
if you quickly screen your grids you
will have overall
collect very small data you will have
overall
ballpark idea how difficult your data
[Music]
set
all right well thank you again uh dr io
so we've got
okay here's another one for dan in terms
of computational overhead
did you compare relative free energy
calculation of a compound versus that
for an
and are there larger simulation boxes
are larger simulation boxes problematic
um so to answer the second half of that
question first
the answer is our lord so our larger
simulation box is problematic
um no unless we go to huge like if we
try to model like a
full you know like viral particle
um but otherwise no um
and for the first um part then
yeah so if we are doing uh free energy
perturbation for example on a small
molecule
compound in the body pocket compared to
a mutation of an antibody antigen system
um it can take um
slightly long i mean of course there
will be the difference you know on
system size
you know if we're comparing a large
system with a small system
um but the other thing that comes into
play is the size of the perturbations
that one makes
um if one is making a small um
you know change like um you know adding
a
methyl group onto a small molecule then
that's obviously very cheap and the
reason that is cheap is that
um the intermediate stages that we have
between our wild type
uh and our and our mutant
are fewer so say there's 12 or 16
up to a maximum um if it's a much larger
perturbation
such as if we're moving from an alanine
to a
arginine much many more atoms are
um are you know changing there therefore
we need more intermediate
steps so maybe up to 24 or 36 steps
to model that correctly so um
tepee is typically um
the amount of computational overhead
is it's similar for similar sizes of
perturbations whether it be
in small molecule or um you know
proteins
but because typically the perturbations
are larger in proteins
then you know anecdotally yeah typically
it takes a little bit
more uh computational resource uh to
make those
thank you so much we have another
question
can alpha fold structures be used for
the de novo design of epitope specific
antibodies
a very interesting question um
well i think we're still exploring the
the um
the limits of alpha fold and and what it
can do i mean it's a it's an amazing
uh thing that they've done um
lenovo design might be quite difficult
um
you would need to predict the um
the you know you need to predict the
a number of different um of antibody
structures
and there are some indications that it
alpha does well for the most challenging
loops so cdr h3
loops again i would need to test that
myself but if you
could work have a workflow in which you
generate a number of sequences
um you
yeah and then you can model those
accurately
um the main concern i have or the main
thought that i have is
um will are you modeling in
a complex or modeling you know um
in the unbound structure and there will
likely be differences there
and again um i think there probably
could be value um
but yeah i think um
it's something that could be explored um
yeah certainly
um yeah so an interesting question
um that's cool uh difficult to answer
thank you dr cannon uh we have another
question here for
yuri have you looked at any cryo-em
protein samples
complex protein to protein less than 100
kilodaltons without using
the fab antigen complex
i didn't i work for the company where
we work a lot of with pubs nano bodies
antigens
i didn't but from the scientific point
of view we don't exclude it
we sometimes have time to do just pure
research
not related to the in a drug candidate
it may may come up in future
but so far i haven't and there was i
think another question about
detectives where the type of detector
affect the outcome
i think nowadays uh detectors are
generally good
it's uh both gatan and thermo fissure
detectors are great
so we don't have a preference at this
point anymore
thank you dr iozo we have time for a few
more questions
um here's the next question at what
phase of antibody discovery are
structures most useful
um i can maybe take that um
and yuri if you have any follow-up um
so i would say having it um
as early as possible is most useful of
course um
because then you can understand the you
know the complexities of
your system earlier um more often
um i've actually seen um
cases where it's
the structure is resolved later in the
discovery stage and i've seen
you know just as it's moving into clinic
and one of the biggest things i've
seen is not really always in terms of
affinity
or stability but actually in terms of
developability there's some
antibodies which have made it into
clinic which are have a
large tendency to aggregate
and at that point you can't really do
anything to
change the sequence what you can do is
is you know use formulation uh
techniques uh to try and mitigate
um the aggregation and this is something
that you know i i've
worked on projects like this before um
where you can only change the the
conditions
and the buffer conditions etc and
yeah so ideally you don't want to
you know negate that problem when it's
in the clinic so
you want to have it earlier in the
discovery phase if possible
yeah i can get a quick comment that
because the
structural biology is a pressure
precious resource
so we don't try to intervene very early
when uh
the discovery campaign going on the
early candidates
only when there is an errors full of the
candidates
we try uh to help if they need it but of
course
or ideally you should have it as soon as
possible and of course
if you have it by uh if you have it at
the time of ip file and it's also
extremely helpful because you can
broaden your claims
well thank you dr iozo and dr cannon uh
looks like that's all we have time for
uh as far as questions go today do
either of you have any final comments
for our audience
yeah uh i want to thank both lab roots
and therma teacher
for brain and mean the end and the same
webinar i think it's very important for
the current uh
biologics research that the structural
biology not
only the tool but rational design
structure assisted or structured
free predictions are so intertwined with
the structural biology and think those
two methods will
complement each other in the future
thank you very much
and yeah and yuri said it perfectly i
think that i i've also learned
a lot from this webinar and you know the
the importance that both cryovm and
structural resolution plays into the
work that we do and
and how it can really be important to
the field in general
again thank you for uh for the
invitation to speak and
yeah thanks again
well thank you again doctor
excuse me i lost my place thank you
again
dr yury iozo and dr dan cannon for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labrus and our
sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye